Speaker 1: All right, let's talk a little
bit about the Saturday Night Live situation,
and then I have voicemail and then we've got
the bonus show and a lot of other things still
to get to.
This is in a sense, it's not really a news
story because it was sort of offhandedly reported
in twenty nineteen.
But now we're learning the full scope of this.
Donald Trump actually did want the satirical
television program Saturday Night Live investigated
for making fun of him.
And of course, there's a couple of stories
here.
One is the incredibly authoritarian perspective
on what should be allowed in media in a country
that supposedly has satirical media, a free
press, et cetera.
We're making fun of politicians, including
presidents, is something that you can do.
That's one piece of it.
The other part of it is just Trump as the
endless victim with like the thinnest possible
skin of anyone that we have ever heard of.
So let's dig into this and look at it piece
by piece.
There's a great Vanity Fair article about
this, and the article is by Best 11.
And it actually quotes The Daily Beast, which
reported it was the middle of Donald Trump's
presidency.
And he was yet again mad at Saturday Night
Live.
And he wanted the federal government to help
him settle the score.
In March of twenty nineteen, the then president
of the United States had just watched an episode
of the long running, liberal leaning and NBC
sketch comedy series wasn't even a new episode.
It was a rerun and grew immediately, incensed
that the show was gently mocking him.
It's truly incredible that shows like Saturday
Night Live not funny.
No talent can spend all of their time knocking
the same person me over and over without so
much of a mention of the other side, Trump
tweeted long before he was banned from Twitter
for inspiring a violent mob like an advertisement
without consequences.
Same with late night shows.
Should Federal Election Commission and or
FCC look into this?
It was on its face a ridiculous question and
threat as SNL is obviously satire and therefore
a form of protected speech in America that
pissed off commanders in chief have no authority
to directly subvert.
However, then President Trump went farther
than simply tweeting his displeasure with
the late night comedians of SNL Writers Room.
The internal discussions that followed between
the former leader of the free world and some
of his political and legal advisers once again
underscored just how much Trump wanted to
use the full weight and power of the U.S.
government to punish his personal enemies.
Now, of course, the tweets we knew about from
2019 since they were public, what's new is
this additional piece that we have now learned
about.
According to two people familiar with the
matter who spoke to The Daily Beast, Trump
repeatedly asked lawyers and advisers what
the FCC, the courts, systems and the Department
of Justice could do to probe or mitigate,
mitigate SNL, Jimmy Kimmel Live and other
late night shows.
Quoting The Daily Beast, one source who has
a law degree said that when they briefly discussed
this with Trump more than two years ago, they
made a point of saying that the Justice Department
in particular doesn't handle these matters
anyway.
Trump seemed disappointed to hear that there
was no actual legal recourse or anything that
the FCC or DOJ could do to punish late night
anti Trump comedy.
Can something else be done about it?
Trump replied, according to the source, to
which they responded with some version of
I'll Look into it.
The person says they never actually looked
into it.
This is horrifyingly authoritarian.
Now, I know that there are many defenders
of Trump who will hear this and they will
simply say, oh, it was just he was just mad
and he was just musing.
He wasn't really saying anyone should look
into it.
Yes, he was.
He was.
And he brought it up multiple times.
He was saying someone should look into it.
Fortunately, no one did, because it would
go completely counter to everything that our
country stands for when it comes to speech
and free press and satire.
But the the really it's not news to us that
Donald Trump had extraordinarily authoritarian,
authoritarian leaning tendencies.
We knew that the part that to me continues
to be stunning is that this is the he was
the most powerful person in the world in the
sense that president of the United States
colloquially considered the leader of the
free world.
There is no one more powerful than the American
president.
Trump himself as a rich dude from New York,
has had an entire life of privilege and power
and went above and beyond what any president
has ever done in terms of trying to limit
the criticism of him, comedic criticism, serious
criticism on news channels, any of it, and
just so extraordinarily thin skinned.
Now, the one other thought.
I don't really care too much about this whole,
like, alpha male, beta male narrative that
many conservatives like, but if you buy into
that narrative.
Is this the behavior of an alpha male, I mean,
by those who like Trump because they see him
as an alpha and think about politicians in
those terms.
Is this how a so-called alpha male behaves?
I think the answer is obviously not.
Zango, could you and could we get the FCC
to investigate the jokes being made about
me?
Absolutely laughable that anybody would see
Donald Trump that way.
And yes, even though the authoritarianism
certainly shouldn't come as a surprise to
us because it's been one of Trump's hallmarks
for a long time, it's still horrifying that
he was regularly trying to use the power of
the federal government to do this stuff.
Next, I want to talk a little bit about Donald
Trump's reaction.
So we already looked at the new reports about
Donald Trump wanting Saturday Night Live investigated
and looked into for satirical content that
they did about Donald Trump, as they've been
doing for president, on presidents, about
presidents for decades.
My guess is that in the past, when the president
was someone other than Trump, Trump didn't
find anything wrong with the satirical commentaries
done by Saturday Night Live.
Now, whether you find them funny or not, that's
another question.
I'm not a big SNL guy, but it is without question
whatsoever that what they do is completely
protected constitutionally and that having
the federal government look into it is absurd.
Donald Trump yesterday put out another one
of these statements where he denies the story,
but sort of kind of like admits it in so doing.
Let's take a look at this statement by Donald
Trump.
Trump says, The story that I asked the Department
of Justice to go after ratings challenged
without Trump, Saturday Night Live and other
late night losers is total fake news.
It was fabricated.
There were no sources, and yet the lame stream
media goes with it.
I did say, however, that Alec Baldwin has
no talent.
Certainly when it comes to imitating me, the
one who had what it took was Darrell Hammond.
This is a former president, guys.
With all of that being said, however, I do
believe that the one hundred percent one sided
shows should be considered an illegal campaign
contribution from the Democrat Party.
Hard to believe I got 75 million votes, the
most of any sitting president, despite all
of that, together with a very fraudulent election.
Twenty four or before.
So in it, Trump actually does say he thinks
that SNL should be illegal.
He is not saying it should be illegal in the
sense that it's being reported that he wanted
it investigated.
But he believes that it counts as a Democratic
campaign contribution, I guess because the
show's existence has monetary value to Democrats,
because they go after Republicans, but not
Democrats.
Now, the truth is SNL sort of goes after both
it.
There is no doubt left leaning is abundantly
clear that it is a left leaning show, but
no president has been exempt from being targeted
by SNL.
But in denying that the story is a real story,
even though he tweeted this stuff out in twenty
nineteen, he tweeted this stuff out in the
tweets that I read to you in the previous
segment, he is saying actually there is criminality
in Saturday Night Live, which is already completely
off the wall, authoritarian and suppressive
of what are constitutionally protected and
not campaign contributions.
Satirical segments on SNL.
It's so funny how this guy in trying to deny
stuff, he often ends up confirming that at
least the belief is true.
And of course, when you publicly tweeted out,
it all is perfectly believable.
Now, Trump also put out one other statement
yesterday, and these statements are so bizarre.
Trump wrote, Georgia now plans to remove over
100000 obsolete and outdated names off their
voter rolls.
Doing this, they say, will ensure voting files
are up to date, while at the same time ensuring
voter integrity in future elections.
But what about the last election?
Why wasn't this done prior to the November
3rd presidential election where they had us
losing by a very small number of votes, many
times less than the one hundred and one thousand
seven eighty nine figure?
This means we you won the presidential election
in Georgia, but don't fret much.
Other information will soon be revealed about
Georgia and other states as well.
It is coming out fast and furious.
The twenty twenty presidential election was
rigged just a word salad of further claims
that he really won and complaints that even
though what George is doing now is good.
They should have done it before because in
reality, he actually won Georgia.
I mean, it is endless with this guy and again,
referencing it's all going to come out very,
very soon.
Very unstable, very unstable and continuing
to just put out what are the equivalent of
tweets.
And this guy is going to do everything he
can to play a celebrity role in twenty, twenty
two.
He wants to be revered.
He wants twenty, twenty two candidates to
come to him and pay a pilgrimage.
Whether it is a literal one or a digital one
or a figurative one or whatever the case may
be, he wants to be the decider for twenty,
twenty two.
And he is so desperate to be that and continuing
to allude to soon we are going to learn the
truth about twenty twenty now.
Really funny.
Mike Lyndell of my pillow.
Just as a quick update, who has been saying
for a couple of weeks now, Trump will be reinstated
in August.
He has now shifted to saying, I might be off
by a month, I might be off by a month or so.
Now, Michael Mondelēz, August is becoming
September y.
Well, August is only five weeks away.
And obviously Trump is not going to be back
in five weeks nor in nine weeks, which would
be the end of August.
So already Mike Lyndell is starting to push
back a little bit and point to September.
They're going to do this all the way until
they just say, hey, you know what, we've got
to just vote in twenty, twenty two.
That's the way to do it, so that then we can
impeach Biden and so then Trump can come back
in twenty, twenty four.
It was written on the wall all along and it's
becoming increasingly clear from these very
strange statements from Donald Trump.